NANDITHA RAM: My
name is Nanditha,
and I'm from the Anthos
partner management.
Team and I'm going
to be joined shortly
by my colleague Evgeniya.
She's from the partner
engineering team.
We are here representing
the entire Anthos team
to thank you, our customers
and partners, for collaborating
with us, for entrusting us
to innovate on your behalf,
so you can build
better functionality
at a faster pace more
reliably and more consistently
for your customers.
You've heard throughout the
day, from our different teams
on the capabilities that
we are building for you,
and will continue
to build for you,
so you can modernize on
Anthos with confidence
that you won't be locked in.
That you can implement policy
and security management
at scale.
Build once to run anywhere.
There is one additional
factor that we
wanted to highlight for you
when you think about what
sets Google Cloud's
Anthos apart,
and it is our growing
ecosystem of partners.
Several of them are
here today with us
and will be joining us
for the reception as well.
We are working with
a variety of partners
who are innovating
on our platform,
building their solutions
integrating their
solutions with Anthos,
and extending Anthos for you.
We have over 40
technology partners
that are working with us to
qualify their solutions to work
with Anthos.
And this includes
the best of breed
of enterprise
commercial solutions,
as well as open source options.
We're working with a
variety of platform partners
so you can make use of your
existing hardware investments,
as well as any new
requirements can be satisfied
using validated
solutions on Anthos
that they are continuously
releasing for you.
We are on-boarding
partners every day
that can help you
as service partners
to migrate and modernize
your solutions swiftly
and successfully.
So if you're
wondering if you can
run your favorite third party
product or tool on Anthos,
the answer is yes.
Whether you're a
developer or an operator,
the GCP marketplace is
your central repository
to find, to deploy, and
use our partner solutions.
Our partners are offering
flexible subscription licenses,
and the advantage of using
the GCP marketplace is you
also get the benefit
of consolidated billing
with your GCP spend.
Specific to Anthos,
we have a number
of operators on Kubernetes and
Kubernetes apps to support you.
These are simple to deploy,
out-of-the-box solutions that
you can deploy through automated
deployment templates onto
your GKE clusters or
your Anthos on prem.
We've also made sure
that we have launched
managed updates, a
feature that helps
both customers and
partners manage updates
to these solutions.
So as a user, you get
notified any time a partner
has an updated version.
As a partner you
don't have to have
the burden of supporting older
versions or outdated versions.
And more importantly,
you have a way
to make sure you can
launch and release
security patches, application
updates, to your customers
in a timely manner.
If you're interested in taking
a look at the types of partner
solutions that are
supported on Anthos,
and if you use the same lens
that the Iglesias and team did,
when it comes to the
infrastructure layers
we have partners
that can support
to you for storage solutions,
be it on prem or online.
You have the choice to bring
to Anthos your preferred load
balancers or ingress proxies,
your preferred security
and identity solution providers.
When you think about
the platform layer,
we have the best of
breed of developer tools
as well as IT ops
monitoring solutions
so that you can develop
on Anthos with confidence.
If you are looking for
application level services,
be it databases, enterprise,
commercial, or open source,
you can see the variety of
options we have for you.
The same holds good for
analytics and newer machine
learning solutions that
we will be bringing
to the GCP marketplace.
To show you how
you can get started
in using the GCP marketplace
and our partner solutions,
I'd like to invite
on stage Evgeniya.
[APPLAUSE]
EVGENIYA SHUMAKHER:
Thank you, Nanditha.
All right.
So I'll try to be short.
I know you're all very tired
and want to just move on
to the happy hour.
But let's talk a little bit
more about why we believe
partners are so important.
So one of the great
promises that Anthos makes
is to accelerate application
development and modernization.
More where we want developers
to focus on what's important.
And what's important is to
bring competitive advantages
to their companies.
And we realize it's impossible
to do it without our technology
partners without building a
robust ecosystem of enterprise
solutions that run on
Anthos and work with Anthos.
So though this
slide says that we
will look at GCP
marketplace, I actually
want to step back and
look at the user journey.
So you will understand
why we think
it's important to
start with users
and then bring partners in.
Could we please launch the demo?
Yeah, I didn't want
to take any chances,
so we'll do it this way.
So a partner in her
opening talk mentioned
that retail and
commerce companies
are very excited about Anthos.
So here you can see--
almost can see-- a
demo, a recording
of the application
that is running.
And this is an
online, boutique shop.
It's very fun and
looks pretty simple,
but, essentially, for
our retail customers,
this is their bread and butter.
This is what their
users see as the end
value of our retail company's
products and offerings.
Not the only one,
but one of those.
When development teams are
working on solutions like that,
it's not just them
having fun, but they also
have to keep in
mind things like how
scalable this application is,
how reliable it is, will they
be able to make sure that
all their customers are
happy during the holiday season?
So with that,
let's look what can
be under the hood
of an application
like I just showed you.
We're going to
launch another demo.
And now we're looking
at GCP console.
So you can see, I have actually
two Kubernetes clusters.
One is on prem cluster,
UC cluster type Anthos.
And the other one
is GKE cluster.
And, in fact, on both
of these clusters
we see serverless
applications running.
And this is the
application that you saw.
Actually, it's
managed by Cloud Run.
The reason developers
could choose
Cloud Run is because it delivers
on the promise of scaling
up and down from zero,
depending on the traffic.
So that kind of serves
this idea of when
you have holiday season
peak and traffic,
Cloud Run can handle that right.
And, at the same
time, our users will
be able to manage
their resources
and make sure they don't spend
too much on the infrastructure.
So we see that that's all great.
So you will ask me, so Evgeniya,
where's partners in all of it?
So the partner comes next.
So we can look at the
architectural overview here.
This is just an example
of all the microservices
the development
team came up with
and their communications
between each other.
What stands out on this diagram
is a data store component.
And while it's all fun
to use open source tools
and manage them
by ourselves, when
it comes to building
POCs and MVPs,
if we want to run an
application in production,
we really want it to
be stable and robust,
and we want certain
guarantees that it won't fail.
And choosing the right
data store solution
is a very important step.
So a lot of our
users will come to us
and say, tell us which data
store providers should we
choose to run on top of Anthos.
And the answer to that
is GCP marketplace.
This is where our
users would go to look
into available databases.
So again, we look at the
cluster, GCP console.
Let's look at the marketplace.
We see all the Kubernetes apps.
Let's filter and see what
sort of database solutions
are available there.
We see 23 results.
You would see some
of those listings
have managed updates available.
This is the version of the app
that supports Mesh updates.
Scrolling down MVC
Redis Enterprise.
So let's say we made a choice--
our user made a choice
to use Redis All right.
Redis actually has
integrated billing.
So what we will
get out of it, we
will get a single unified
Anthos bill together with Redis.
So our procurement team
doesn't have to worry about it.
So we look through.
There is plenty of
documentation available,
thanks to Redis Enterprise team.
And here we are.
We just configuring, choosing
the right flavor, the pricing,
hitting deploy button,
and getting deployed.
And obviously, you all can go
and check it out yourselves
if you have GCP account and you
have billing admin permissions,
right?
Here it is.
Operator is deployed.
The application
is being deployed.
All right.
So this is all the
goodness that users
can get out of GCP marketplace.
And by the way, we actually
support on prem deployments
as well.
So whether you want to deploy
an application for Marketplace
on cloud or on prem, it is
going to be the same experience
as long as your cluster
fits the requirements
for the application.
Is that it?
Is that all that we
do with partners?
Absolutely not.
When we talk to our
users, we understand
that actually adopting
Anthos is a huge commitment.
And working on application
modernization takes time.
So asking users to adopt new
development operation tools
would be a big overhead.
So what do we want?
We want to meet our
customers where they are.
We want just to embed Anthos
into existing developer
and operation workflows and make
sure that existing tools just
work as fine.
So this diagram is one
of the good examples
of a collaboration that
we had with Jfrog team
to build an end-to-end
solution workflow
and show our customers how they
can use their private companion
registry in the
hybrid cloud setup.
And this is what we do with many
more customers and partners.
We're getting feedback
from customer teams
of what kind of solutions they
are looking for and bringing
those to partners and
work together on that.
So it's not just a diagram.
This is something that any
user can take and adopt
any moment they want to.
Another commitment that we
make, not just to our customers
but also to our
partners, is to make sure
that we bring Anthos
roadmap to them.
We're talking about
new components
that we bring into
the Anthos ecosystem
and making sure that
those are seamlessly
integrated with partner
products as well.
One of the recent
launches that we had
was Cloud Run for Anthos
our server component
and together with
Cloud Run for Anthos.
We announced an ecosystem
of more than 10 partners
who now officially support
Cloud Run for Anthos out of box.
With that, I'm passing
the ball back to Nanditha
to wrap up our session.
Thank you.
NANDITHA RAM: Thank
you, Evgeniya.
I hope that give everybody a
glimpse of how easy and simple
it is to use solutions
from our partners.
But Evgeniya said, and you
saw earlier in the day,
we want to take steps further
and further with our partners.
So our approach to solving what
our customers and users are
asking from us is to use
Google's first party solutions
and third party solutions
from our partners,
stitch them together so
every user and every customer
gets a first party-like
reliable experience.
So you will see more and
more solution maps coming out
from us similar to
the CI/CD tooling
solution set that Vacant team
showed you earlier today.
And if you want to collaborate
with us on building solutions,
we want to work with you.
And we want to hear from you.
So I do hope we can
continue the conversation.
Our team is going to be
at the Google Cloud booth.
We're going to be here
the rest of Cube Con.
And more importantly,
we're going
to be on the rooftop
for the party.
So do come join us and
talk to us about solutions
that you want to build
together with us.
To give you more options on
how you can stay connected
with our entire Anthos team
through KubeCon and beyond,
I want to invite on
stage our group product
manager, Sambit Samal.
SAMBIT SAMAL: Thanks, Nanditha.
Good afternoon.
So, closing times.
I guess this is the moment
you all have been waiting for.
But one of the goals
that we had for this day
is to help you understand
Anthos a little bit better.
So, considering where we started
in the morning, how many of you
would say that they have
a better idea of Anthos
now versus what was
there in the morning.
By the show of hands?
OK.
Looks like many of you still
do not know what Anthos is.
So this next slide is
for those primarily.
So we have a rooftop
reception at 6:00 PM.
So join us there.
All of us and all the
presenters will be there.
There'll be more experts.
So you can talk to
them over drinks,
and maybe that'll help you
understand the things better.
And if you miss that, we
have a community booth
you can go and
sign up, and we'll
be happy to talk to you
about Anthos and anything
that you want to talk.
And we have a booth
on the Expo floor.
You can come there,
and we can have a chat.
On your table, there is an
e-book about Service Mesh
Please take that home.
That'll help you understand
Service Mesh better.
And we have a
shuttling to YouTube
video that will also be helpful
to learn more about Anthos.
Please use those resources.
And with that, we will
love your feedback.
And please provide
this feedback.
Either you can use
the Chromebook outside
or use any of the links here.
But before I do that,
before I wrap it up,
we have a winner from
the last feedback
that happened 10 minutes back.
The winner is team [INAUDIBLE].
If he's here.
Ravin has the gift for you.
[APPLAUSE]
All right, that's it.
Thank you everyone for
joining us here today.
Hope you had a good time.
It was valuable.
Thank you.